hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
development and analytical validation of
prognostic biomarkers for
metastasis i'm susie valdez of labrutz
and i will be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots and brought to you by vizio
farm
to learn more visit them at
videofarm.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
might have during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
i'd now like to welcome our speaker dr
david
entenberg an assistant professor at the
department of anatomy and structural
biology at albert
einstein college of medicine david
welcome you may now begin your
presentation
well thank you for that introduction um
so as you heard my name is david
entenberg and i come from einstein
college of medicine where i serve as the
director of technological development
within the crosslipper biophotonic
center and it's integrated
imaging program and today i'm going to
be telling you a bit about the efforts
that we have going on at einstein to
develop
and analytically validate prognostic
biomarkers that are specific
for metastasis and so as a summary of
what i'm going to tell you
i'm going to talk a little bit about the
preclinical research that we have done
over the years
in order to discover two new biomarkers
that are specific
for the process of metastasis and these
are then
different from traditional biomarkers
which really tend to measure
proliferation and growth potential of
tumors
these biomarkers that we've discovered
are really mechanistically linked to
dissemination and metastasis
so i'm going to tell you a bit about how
they were discovered and how we
performed some clinical validation of
these
biomarkers and how we've been using
digital pathology to
automate the tests for uh high
throughput
and eventual clinical use how we've been
showing
reproducibility and analytically
validating these these new biomarkers
and then i'll wrap it up i tell you uh
some of our latest work which is how
we're using
digital pathology to improve upon the
prognostication
ability of of these different biomarkers
and so to jump into it i'll first talk
about
how we've discovered these new
biomarkers for metastasis
so we've done cancer research at
einstein for quite a number of years
and we've taken traditionally taken a
pretty unique approach to cancer
research
and that is we rely pretty heavily on
intravital multi-photon microscopy
we really like this technique because
multi-photon microscopy
has the ability to illuminate a single
slice in an otherwise whole
live tumor and create images that are
very reminiscent
of what you would get from mechanically
sectioning and staining tissues
like in a standard histopathology lab
and that that technique can then reveal
histological
uh features um but it also has the
ability to
reveal the dynamics of cells since it is
imaging inside of the live tumor
and what you see on the right here is a
video that we
took um inside of a
primary breast cancer and what you can
see is
the tumor cells in green and the
macrophages in
and the multi-photon microscopy because
it's imaging live
can really give you the dynamics of of
that
of those cells and um by imaging many
many of these tumors what we realized is
that macrophages and tumors
tumor cells actually travel together
inside
of primary tumors where they migrate in
directed streams toward blood vessels
and when they arrive at that blood
vessel they tend to stop their motion
and dock onto that blood vessel forming
a
structure that we call the tumor micro
environment of metastasis
that is the green tumor cell the blue
macrophage
and the red endothelial cell that makes
up the the blood vessel wall
and these um we discovered by doing more
intravital
um multiple time microscopy we
discovered that these
macrophages inside the tmem structures
can poke and prod
at the blood vessel in order to open up
the door
so to speak into the vasculature and
when that happens you get
this leakage of vascular contents into
the interstitium
which shows up here since it the blood
serum was labeled by a red dye
as this burst of of uh dye that flows
out into the interstitium
finally through more intravital imaging
of these uh tmem structures we're able
to go
and see that when that door opens other
tuber cells are able to flow
into the vasculature and then spread
hematogenously
here you can see uh all of those tumor
cells which wind up flowing in
and so this is the moment when the tumor
cells actually
intravenously and spread to secondary
sites
and so all of this research has really
shown us that uh
tmem are the function as doorways
for other tumor cells to intravisit and
spread to
secondary sites like the bone or the
brain or the lung
now we ask the question next what's so
special about these motile cells
and in order to answer that we developed
another assay that we call the in vivo
invasion assay which is the only assay
that can separate
those motile cells from the rest of the
bulk tumor
what the assay consists of is a a set of
artificial blood vessels what we call
artificial blood vessels and these are
just micro needles
that are filled with the growth factor
that can attract those motile cells
which approach the needle and actually
crawl up inside of the needle
after that you can take the needles out
expel the contents onto
a petri dish and then do
analyze them with other other methods so
when we did that we did expression
profiling of those motile cells
and what we identified through that was
the protein
called mena which is an actin regulatory
protein and we found that mena is
very highly upregulated in those motile
cells compared to the rest of the bulk
tumor
now mena is a protein that has a number
of different
splice isoforms
alternatively spliced isoforms and some
of those isoforms
one in particular that's called vena 11a
is highly associated with the epithelial
phenotype kind of like a normal
breast architecture whereas the others
are associated more with mesenchymal
phenotypes that when they are over
expressed in the cell
that the cell becomes highly motile and
migratory
and so we've developed this metric that
we call meena calc
which measures the fraction of those
mena isoforms that are specifically
associated with metastasis
and therefore we can put a number onto
that tumor
that describes how much those tumor
cells inside
are able to migrate and so taken
together
these new findings really presented us
with a new model for metastasis
one wherein some of the tumor cells
inside of the primary tumor
become meaning calc high and they pair
up with macrophages
and they start migrating together toward
the blood vessels
once they reach the blood vessels they
either assemble new tmem doorways
or they interact with tmem doorways that
are pre-existing
those tm doorways then open up the door
to the vasculature and allow these
migrating tumor cells to intravisit
spread to secondary sites where they can
grow into metastases
and so we asked the question can we use
team m
and meena calc these two new insights as
biomarkers specifically for metastasis
and in order to do this we created two
immunostaining protocols
both of them working on formal and fixed
paraffin embedded patient samples
and this is really important because we
wanted to be able to validate
and and show that these biomarkers work
well and you know the only way to really
do that is to
do this in a number of retrospective
samples
retrospective studies where you take
samples
that had been excised from patients 20
years ago
and then you ask the question how did
they fare whether
when your biomarker is high or low
and so the first of these uh protocols
is called we call mean a calc
and it's a quantitative
immunofluorescence assay that consists
of
three different antibodies staining for
the
pan mena which is an antibody that seems
all of the isoforms of mena
and mean 11a which is again that
epithelial associated
uh isoform of mena and
meena calc is then calculated as the
difference between
all of the isoforms or you just take the
all of the isoforms and you subtract
away
that epithelial isoform and this is then
a metric
of how invasive those tumors are
we additionally use cytokeratin in order
to
limit where we consider where we take
signal from
the the amino proteins to just the
membrane
and exclude the nucleus or anything
outside of the tumor cells
just because um the mean of protein is
actually a membrane-bound protein
as you can see in the images on the
bottom
the other staining protocol that we
developed is a triple
immunohistochemistry stain
again on fixed tissues that is just
marks the
component cells of of t mem structures
so we use panmena to identify all of the
tumor cells
and then cd31 for endothelial cells and
cd68 for macrophages
once we have those stains our
pathologists can come in and see
where all of these three cells lie in
contact
with each other in direct contact with
each other and then the pathologists
just put a circle down on top of all of
the team structures
and uh the tmem doorways and then they
count up the number of circles
in a certain area of of tissue
okay so now that we have these two
stains we needed to clinically validate
these biomarkers
and so we did this in a number of of
different studies we have two for media
calc and several others for tmem
then all of these span uh several
thousand
patient samples and what we found is
indeed
the um tmem and mina calc markers are
prognostic for specifically for
metastasis
and this really makes them unique
because most of the
tests that are clinically available such
as ihc4 or oncotype dx
these are our measures of
the expression of genes that are
specific for tumor growth
and not for dissemination potential
and indeed when we uh compared uh
in a large cohort the t-mem score of
individual patients to their oncotype dx
score
what we found is that there was
absolutely no correlation
of outcomes that um or
scores between the two um uh
markers and that really indicates to us
that
both team m score and oncotype dx score
are
giving us distinct biology and so
there's new information that tmm scores
is providing so with this uh with this
confidence now that
these biomarkers actually do provide
information and
can prognosticate outcome for for
patients
we asked how can we prepare this test
for the clinic
well if you're going to
run this test as part of uh
you know by a small biological study
having everything done
manually is just fine but once you want
to start to use this as an actual test
for um for patients you need
a higher throughput method for um
for doing this so we decided we're going
to develop a high-throughput analysis
technique
and so we turned then to digital
pathology for this high throughput
automation and so the story that i'll
tell you today
is focusing on the our efforts to
automate
team m which we just published last year
in the journal cancers
um there's a similar story but that i
could tell for meena calc but
it's um due to the time restrictions
i'll only be able to go into the one
um so for tmem when we wanted to
automate
the the process what we wanted to do is
we wanted to really mimic the
pathologist's workflow as closely as
possible we didn't want to completely
throw it out
and use some other techniques like
artificial intelligence
we really wanted to stick to what the
pathologist had shown
works well and so for the the procedure
that the pathologist had worked out
was to cut and manually stainless slides
then to view those slides at high
magnification
on their microscope and then they would
identify the regions of high vascularity
in the tumor tissue
acquire and save 10 high power fields of
view from their
microscope and then score the images in
photoshop
and altogether each case took the
pathologists about an hour of time
we wanted to dramatically cut this down
so the automated procedure that we came
up with
replaced the manual staining with
automated staining on an autom on a
high-throughput
autostainer and then we replaced the
viewing and acquiring of
images on a microscope with a digital
whole slide scan
we then used software in order to
identify and segment
the invasive tumor from the stroma and
to identify the macrophages and blood
vessels within the tumor
and then finally we identified the tmm
structures based on their morphology
and their juxtapositioning and then
finally we would
cut that tissue up into the equivalence
of
these high high power fields of view and
rank and score the tmm
in the top 10 fields top 10 ranking
fields
all in all we were able to reduce the
amount of pathologist time from about an
hour per case
to down to about five minutes mostly
just for quality control
and so in order to understand this whole
process i'll walk you through it next
but in order to understand the process
let me just mention briefly what digital
pathology is and how we're using it
so digital pathology uses digital whole
slide scanning
it's basically a machine that can go and
scan the entire tissue
by acquiring thousands of uh high
resolution
images that span the entire tissue and
then stitch them together to create
one giant super image it then creates
down sampled versions of those images
so that you can seamlessly switch
between
magnifications very much like you're
using google earth where you can
view the world and then a country and
then
somebody an individual house and so
the real power of digital pathology is
not just though in viewing the tissue
it's that we can actually perform single
cell
quantitative analysis on any one of
these individual tiles
and then apply that analysis tissue wide
and one of the software packages that we
use
to do this is viz by by vizio farm
so what does the process actually look
like well
first we start with the digital whole
slide scan
so here's the entire microscope slide
we can then zoom in and zoom in and zoom
in again until you get down to the
single cell level
we did this on our 3d his tech panoramic
p250
and we scanned at uh 40x taking
6500 fields in really under three
minutes
um then we developed a series of custom
developed apps within uh viz from visio
farm
and the first one was just to perform
the invasive tumor identification and
segmentation
so we know where we want to apply our
future analyses
and then we analyzed that tissue at very
high magnification
using color decompolation to identify
the stain
of all of the the tissue using k-means
clustering we could classify
each and the the color in each and every
pixel
into one of the categories of blood
vessels macrophages
tumor or stroma and at that point
we could use the morphometric analysis
capabilities of physiopharm
in order to identify the macrophages and
blood vessels
that were in direct contact with each
other and in direct contact with tumor
cells around
and here's just a zoom in of one of
those where you can see on the left
the identification of the tumor cells
the the macrophages and the endothelial
cells
and on the right what visio form was
able to identify in an automated fashion
and then we apply that single cell
analysis across the entire tissue
at that point we can cut up the tissue
and rank and
score and rank all of the fields of view
and then
the algorithm is able to present us with
the 10
top ranked fields of view from which we
can generate an overall skull
score for the whole tissue so now that
we have an algorithm and we have a
a process a method for evaluating tmm we
wanted to
validate that process how well does it
perform how does it compare
to what the pathologists were doing
manually
so we again turn uh we're now using this
digital pathology for analytical
validation
and so in order to do this what we did
was we picked out several measures of
reproducibility and accuracy
and evaluated them in order to see how
each step of that process was being
performed
and of course you know the first thing
that we wanted to do was to evaluate how
well do
pathologists perform the t-mem
identification
and so what we did was we took 100 test
fields of view that contained a variety
of numbers of tmem doorways in them and
we gave them to two pathologists on two
different days and we asked them to to
score them
and what we found is that within
observer right so one pathologist on day
one and day two
they agree with themselves uh to a high
degree
with 96 of the time uh on for both
pathologists they agree with themselves
on the next day
but they also agree between themselves
so there's a high level of agreement 92
percent of the time
between pathologist 1 and pathologist 2.
next we wanted to ask how well can the
algorithm do a similar kind of thing so
we gave
all of the slides over to the algorithm
scanned them
twice on two separate days and we asked
how reproducibly
could the algorithm identify those team
m doorways
and what we find is unsurprisingly
because it's a machine
the day-to-day reproducibility was
perfect agreeing with itself 100 of the
time
the machine does what the machine does
right so
the next step was to ask how well
does the algorithm perform in
identifying
tmem structures within a field of view
that's given to it so you
give the algorithm one particular image
and you say
count up the number of of tmm doorways
in this
how well does it prepare how well does
it perform doing that
so we gave we picked out 10 fields of
view
per case that were selected by one
pathologist
and we gave them to the machine and to a
pathologist another pathologist for team
mem scoring
and what we found is that we also get a
high level
of correlation between the scores that
are generated
about 86 percent of the time they agree
finally we wanted to test the whole
procedure and the whole procedure
involves
giving a pathologist the entire
microscope slide and saying
there's no restrictions go look anywhere
you want on the slide
and go pick out a field of view score it
for the tm square and return me
a result for the entire slide and then
we do the same thing
for for the machine algorithm and so we
did this
we actually did this with five different
pathologists scoring and then we
compared the average of those five
scores to
the the machine generated algorithm and
what we found is actually an even higher
level of
correlation between the pathologists and
the algorithm
where they agree about 94 of the time
and
we believe that this is higher than the
86 because
we use the average of five different
pathologist scores
and it seems like the the pathologist to
pathologist
variation seem to be driving down the
score when we we just compared
individual fields of view
okay so now that we have this validated
test it's ready to go into the clinic
we decided we're going to go and see
what what would be the next thing
that we could do to move this uh
to improve upon the performance of these
biomarkers
and so this is our current work that
we're probably in the next week or so
going to submit for publication
um it's been the work of dr shan jun yeh
who's a postdoc a very talented postdoc
in the lab and um he was asking the
question
can we actually improve that
prognostication how would we go about
doing that
and so the way to do it the the
rationale
is you can get to the rationale by
thinking about
what these biomarkers are actually
telling us biologically
so the tmem biomarker is a
quantification
of the number of doorways into the
vasculature that there
are inside of a primary tumor and the
mean of calc
is a quantification or measure of the
level of cell motility
for the tumor cells that are in there
but what you realize
through this then is that if
uh if you have no motile cells but you
have lots of
team m doorways you're not going to get
a lot of metastasis because none
there are no moving cells to pass
through those doorways
and and go to secondary sites similarly
if you have um no tmm doorways but lots
of moving cells
those cells can't go anywhere they can't
get access to the the vasculature
and so in this case no team in doorways
means that you're not going to have an
appreciable level of metastasis
only when you have both
motile cells and an appreciable number
of tmm doorways so that those cells can
get into the vasculature
will you get hematogenous spread and
metastasis
and so we asked the question then how
can we
effectively take these two
mechanistically linked biomarkers and
combine them
in order to to take advantage of this
insight so a simple way of course to do
this
is to say we're going to combine or call
this combined marker high
when both of the individual tests are
high
and high is really determined by a cut
off threshold
that effectively separates a patient
population
between a group that where they're not
going to have metastatic recurrence and
a group where they are going to
and so for each individual score for
each individual biomarker
we can say that a tmem score for a
particular case
is considered high if it's above that
cutoff and low
if it's below that cut off and similar
for
meena calc the combined marker then
would be high if both tmem
and minicalc for that particular patient
is high
and low in all other cases
but before we can just go ahead with
that simple uh method
there's another complication which is
that t-mem and meaning calc
are measured uh differently
tmem is actually measured
only in the top ten fields whereas mean
a calc
is measured across the entire slide
and so there could be several different
ways of combining team mem
and mean a calc they may there may be
spatial associations you may need to
have
um team amino calc measured in the exact
same region
or there may be no spatial connection as
at all in addition we don't know what
the
impact of tissue heterogeneity is how
much of that tissue
do you need to acquire is ten fields of
view enough or do you need to go larger
and finally we want so so given all this
we wanted to test a number of different
ways
of combining all of these markers
and so what we did was we started out by
defining
what are the different tests that we're
actually going to to try out and
evaluate
so we started by defining the extent of
the tissue which is really a way of
accounting for tissue heterogeneity we
can either measure
the entire tissue or we could have our
pathologist
limit that area to where they felt that
would be
most representative of that tissue
and then within each of those regions of
interest
we could either analyze the number of
tmm doorways across the entire
region of interest or we could just pick
out the top 10 fields of view
in each one so all in all if you number
these one two three and four
it gave us four different tests that we
could evaluate
and compare and once we evaluated those
of course
now we have to mix in the mean of calc
in those same areas and but there's an
additional consideration
which is that prior studies using nina
calc
limited the quantification of the
signals to just the cytoplasm
by a cytokeratin mask and it's really
never been tested whether this was
necessary so we additionally wanted to
to test that out
and so given those four different areas
and the two different possibilities for
the
cytokeratin mask that leaves eight
different combinations for mean italic
so we have four tmm analyses and eight
meaning calc analyses
that results in 32 different
combinations
that's a lot of combinations so what we
said though is
that not all 32 combinations are really
consistent
in roi type and tissue coverage so we
wanted to only test those things
that used the same uh roi type and
tissue coverage for both
uh both individual biomarkers
and so that paired the 32 choices down
to only eight
which used the same roi type and tissue
coverage so how do we evaluate which one
is best
well the the first step is to evaluate
how
each uh individual biomarker tmm and
meaning calc
separate the patient population based
upon
time to distance recurrence and so how
do we do this what we do is we adjust
that cut point
which which defines uh whether a patient
is in the high
group or in the low group and then we
look at how they fared over time
using a kaplan-meier analysis and what
we see
when we do this is that the t-mem and
nina calc
tests alone they work fairly well they
create
we can select cut points for all of them
and get the p values
and then we can combine them using that
uh text of the logical end
operation that i mentioned before to get
the p values for the combined markers
but it's a little bit difficult to just
tell whether there's any improvement
in um in by by just looking at the
p-values
and so what we did was we developed a
better metric which is to convert those
p-values
to fold changes and the way we do that
is we take the ratio of tmem to the
combined marker
or the mean account to the combined
marker analysis to generate
fold changes in performance gain right
and what you can see from this is that
the combined marker
almost always improves prognostication
versus tmem
or the meaning calc analysis alone
and you can see that because all of the
numbers are larger than one except for
the team
m4 mc8 which is a 0.5 so only in that
one case does it not outperform the
individual
biomarker and what you can also see is
that
you actually get a better improvement in
general
for meena calc than you do for tmem the
numbers are are typically higher for
uh fold improvements for the performance
gain
in mean account than for tina
so which one is actually best well in
order to narrow it down
we decided to highlight um just those
scores
where team m the team gain is greater
than 5
and the mean a calculate in is greater
than 10.
and this yields two winners we can see
the team m1
mc2 is a winner and team m4 mc7
is also a winner but if you look at the
values team m4 mc7 has a fold gain of
11.3
and 6.9 for the two over the two
individual biomarkers
whereas the other test the team m1 mc2
has a performance gain of 175 and 187
so the best clear the clear best
performer gives us a greater than
hundred and seventy fold improvement
over both team and nina cal colon
so how well does that best performer
separate the population
um well you can see here that the tmem
and the meaning calc analysis are able
to separate the populations
uh somewhat well but when we evaluate
the same cohort with the combined marker
analysis
we can see a dramatic improvement in in
segregation between those two
separation between those two groups so
the combined marker analysis
dramatically improves the prognosis of
distant metastases
and what does that winner look like will
the best performer analyze tmem over the
entire tissue
and excluded the nuclear menical signals
by using
the cytokeratin mask and this really
indicates to us that the tissue
heterogeneity
and non-specific meanest staining are
crucial factors
so in summary i told you about how we
discovered these new biomarkers from
metastasis
and how we did clinical validation of
these biomarkers
using digital pathology to show
reproducibility and to analytically
validate them
and then how now we're trying to use
digital pathology to improve
prognostication
and all of this work has really been
made possible by the gruff liquor
biophotonic center
and its associated integrated imaging
program at einstein
where the mandates are to develop novel
technologies and to use those novel
technologies in order to bridge to the
clinic
and what i've told you today is just one
story that we have in collaboration with
the department of pathology
but there are several others with
department of surgery and
our healthcare industry partners and
collaborators both
across the u.s and abroad i'll end up
with just showing you the clinical
and basic science research team which
spans a number of different institutions
that work together under the auspices of
the new york pathology oncology group
and i'll finish up with just displaying
my acknowledgment slide
and take any questions that you guys
have thank you
and thank you david for that informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
and joining david is regan baird the
regional manager for
vizio farm east i want to remind our
audience members that if you have any
questions you want to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
so let's take a look reading david we
have quite a few questions
already coming in our first question
is the two tests that you've developed
use different modalities tmem
is an immunohistochemical
stain and minicalc is an amino
fluorescent
stain why not make them ihc
or bose i s
great thanks thanks um for the question
so um
yes they're both taken in different
modalities
but they are fundamentally measuring
different things about the tissue so
um immunohistochemical stains are
typically not very quantitative
in the stain the the process of the
development of the chromogen
actually is a pretty non-linear process
whereas immunofluorescence
the amount of light signal that you get
from a
a chroma from a fluorophore can be
quantified and related directly to
the protein expression level and so uh
for meeting a calc where we're really
interested in the level of the isoform
expression we use the immunofluorescence
however for the t m stain what we're
really more interested in
is the morphological uh um
the morphology of the tissue
that is the juxtaposition of the three
different cell types so we're really
looking in that case more for a yes or a
no
answer to is this particular cell a
macrophage or is it a tumor cell and
what is it next to
and so that's why uh we really use these
different um
the two different modalities
[Music]
as part of our uh second study where we
compared
uh the two biomarkers we used and tried
to create the combined marker
uh it was really important since we were
using those two different
modalities to be able to use some of the
to align features within visio farm that
really could align those two different
images
the two slides down to the single cell
level and that gave us the ability to
have confidence
that we were looking at the same region
sometimes the same cell
within the tissue in order to be able to
evaluate
both the morphology of of the team
and the expression level of the isoform
of protein isoforms
thank you so much now what is the
hypothesis
for the clinical value of the tmm
results for guiding
the decisions of management of patient
therapy
well thanks that's actually another good
question sometimes it's not so
clear you know why you would want to be
able to specifically measure
the level of dissemination and really
the answer is because
metastasis and metastatic spread
is really what is responsible for
the overwhelming majority of mortality
in
breast cancer the problem
that clinicians face is that they don't
know
who is going to have metastatic disease
and who isn't and so
pretty much everyone who uh
has tumors of a certain characteristics
or over a certain size
or a certain grade winds up getting
chemotherapy
just because we don't know who
who has metastatic disease and who
doesn't and so that
leads to potentially to a lot of over
treatment of patients and and these
treatments can be
very costly in terms of money
they're expensive treatments but also in
terms of quality of life
they're very harsh they are you know
cytotoxic
therapies um and so if we can reduce the
amount of
over treatment then that will have a
very significant impact upon
lives of patients in addition there's
also a smaller subset
of patients who potentially would have
metastatic disease
but it's not apparent from their primary
tumor and so
the tests like meena calc and tmem are
really designed
to to try to identify that particular
population
that's going to have uh disseminating
disease and
would benefit the most from uh
from cytotoxic chemotherapies and also
you know to
to identify those that would not benefit
thank you very much and i want to also
thank our audience members for these
great questions
coming in our next question from an
audience member
is there a difference in the mental
health value
obtained from different parts of tumors
or
different areas of the tumor that may be
hypoxic
so i guess the question is really about
the heterogeneity of
of the munich calc and
part of what we tried to address in this
second study with the combined marker is
what really what is the impact of tissue
heterogeneity
on the the prognostic ability of this
biomarker and
what we're finding is that um tissue
heterogeneity exists
and uh it is actually a bit detrimental
to
our our ability to prognosticate and so
the
solution that we've um believe we've
struck upon
with the results of our combined marker
analysis is that
the um is that
uh taking the mean account
or averaging or the mean a calc over the
entire tissue slide
is probably the best way to go and that
way you you tend to
um average out the areas that are
um a heterogeneous and
areas like hypoxic areas we're finding
in other studies
actually do have an impact upon
both tmm formation and meaning calc
expression
and so that these are these conditions
of hypoxia
wind up leading to increased levels of
dissemination
thank you very much now how does your
combined
biomarker analysis relate to
local relapse and lymph node metastasis
compared to distant metastasis
so what we have been studying
is uh really um
geared toward an analysis of distant
metastasis
um local relapse is best measured
by other metrics of that are more
closely related to
growth so for example i showed the
comparison to oncotype dx this is a
a gene analysis which
really tell us about the growth
potential what are the
cell proliferation genes that are up
regulated inside of the tumor
and that would wind up leading to local
relapse
the difference between lymph node
metastasis and distant metastases
it's not clear but an additional
complication
to that is that it's been recently
published by
our group and by other groups that
dissemination hematogenous dissemination
can also occur from secondary sites like
lymph node metastases
and in particular in a study that we
published just last year
what we discovered was that um tm
doorways actually exist
can be visualized inside of uh
of lymph node metastases and so um
the presence of tumor metastases inside
of lymph nodes
could be an indicator of
a further spread and
that's due to team mem and so
by being able to
assess the level of team m doorway and
mean account involvement
in the primary tumor it could
potentially inform you
about uh the dissemination
um uh competence of of um
lymph node mets as well
thank you so much and we have time for
one more question
are these biomarkers specific only to
breast tissue
um so no they're not specific uh only to
breast tissue
uh i believe that um uh
right so we've done most of our studies
inside of breast tissue but we believe
that
the tmm and minicalc biology is actually
common to
all solid cedenocarcinomas and we
have been able in our studies to see
this in lung adenocarcinoma
pancreatic suctional adenocarcinoma um
breast cancer and uh there's one more
that's uh
ewing sarcoma i've seen we've even
observed these team member doorways in
and so the studies that we have going on
in fact there are even a couple of
clinical trials uh
looking at inhibitors of of um
dissemination in a variety of different
cancers
we feel that this prognostic that we've
developed
should have utility for a wide variety
of cancers
david i want to thank you again for your
time today
would you like to provide some final
comments for our audience members before
we go
uh sure yeah so i i just think um
that uh the type of work that we're
doing in addition to being
you know fascinating and interesting um
has the potential really to
to um make an impact upon patients lives
and so
um we're really excited to be able to
bring these to fruition and um
to partner up with companies like vizio
farm
where a lot of times
our initial idea sounds crazy and it's a
somewhat impossible to do but if you go
and find the right partners then
it actually makes it possible
thank you so much david and thank you
for your time and for your important
research and thank you
for joining us today regan for the q a
i'd also like to thank
lab roots and our sponsor vizio farm for
underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go i want
to thank our audience
for joining us today and for their
interesting questions and questions we
did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
take care stay healthy stay safe bye-bye
everyone
great thank you so much